ήρθες σε μένα τονά αυτόν το θέωμ ν ενώ να πήγαινε στον υπεύθυνο δε να
ληθεί και πιο γρήγορα γιατί εγώ να πάρω των υπέύθυνον τηλέφωνο να τον εύρον ενώ
αν επήγαινες απευθείας εκείς των υπεύθυνο καθααγρίας πάεϊμο εχαρί να λέετον εταφορές πιον κληγορατο το
πρόβλημα αλλά στηγκή προ έχουν και τα καλά μας έχουμε και να κακά μας το
καλώ μας είαι όι είμαστε πιο μικρή κοινωνία εγνωρίζο ένα στων άλλο υπάρχει μια πιο
ανθρωποι νη σχέση αλλά το συναι πακόλουθον να οπόμιον έκτημα αυτής της μικρής κοινωνίας είναι
ότι έχεις αυτά τα πράγματα δηλαδή όταν περπαρά τον τρόμο κιρθει ένας άνθρωπος και σε
βρει εναι και αγένεια να του πεις δεν με διαφέρει αυτό το πρόβλημα προσπαθίζα φερικά
κάποιες φρές χανεται κι υπομονή αλλά σε ένα μεγάλον βαθμόν είναι ένα χαρακτηριστικώ της πατρίας
μας στο οποίο και ευτυχώς πολλές φορές και δυστιχώς κάποιες φορές ποεμε ατιμετωπίσεις γένωση δήμο
για των αντρέα δήρα είναι άλλη μια καρέκλα αντιθέτος θεωρώ ότι είναι μιαέναν μέσων ακριβώς
διεκπερίωσεις αυτό που επιστεύω καλύτερα γιατην τοπική ν αυτο διήγηση διαδή τοπ γι αυτογήσμαρεσι είναι
κάτι το οποίον έχει πάρα πολλά έτση ν απόβάρι αλλά το καλό τις είναι ότι
είσαι κοντά των κόσμο ότι διάς λύσεις στον κόσμο βλέπει στα αποτελέίσμανα τον ενεργις του
εθαδίσ να ανεργο θαδής θα δείς δεν είναι παστη βουλή αν περάσει ένα νομοσχέδι όδέλειο
ότι είναι εναι θημαντικός ο όλος του γυλευτή αντιθέως αλλά η διαφορά το υμάρχο χεις
και μιαν εκτελιστική εξουσία δηλαδή οι κάποιες πράξεις του θαριζήσει την πράξει θα περάσεις θαίσει
το εργο θα δής ότι παίζουν τα μορά εκεί αυτό που έγαμειώθει στη βελκτίωση όταν
πλίμη όταν βρέχει ότι αυτός ο τρόμος που έγανε σε αυτόν το έργον δεν πλημύρησε
άρα θεωρώ ότι ι ένωσι δήμω που δίνειτη δυναδόταν ακριβώς γιατί ένας δημάρχος από μόνωσει
το δεν μπορεί ούτε νομοθεσίες να αλλάξει τε να χειπάρι μβάσεις σε σημαντικά ζητήματα ότι
ι ένω δημο είναι να μέσον ι το οποίον θεωρώ ότι βοηθών να συντωήνι αυτο
ήκηση βουεθας τον κόσμοι διάληση κάποιο δήμο με τα και από τι νέα κατάσταση πράγματο
στην τοπική ν αυτό οδήγηση θεωρείται ότι